I've been running a survey over these
past couple of months actually and I've
I've been giving out psychometrically a
special psychometrically validated
questionnaire which tests the the the
presence of psychopathic traits within
members of the general population I've
been giving it out to friends of mine
who are film critics actually and I've
been asking them to to write various
iconic figures in film for where they
where they fall on various
characteristics and if we take say the
iconic spy figure James Bond the the
British Secret Service agent double-oh 7
himself you find that James Bond is
probably one of the most nailed down
functional Psychopaths that there is I
mean James Bond he's ruthless he's
fearless he's extremely focused he's
mentally tough he's of course absolutely
without conscience and remorse he's one
of the biggest philanderers that's ever
worked for the British Secret Service
although I couldn't say that hand on
heart officially but I do know some of
them but I mean James Bond is is is
absolutely one of the classic examples
of a functional psychopath those
characteristics are being used to
benefit society rather than detract from
society you know I've I've interviewed a
lot of Special Forces soldiers and you
know what in Special Forces you can't
afford to to dwell on the fact that
you've pulled the trigger and killed
someone you know if you do then the next
bullet could be going through your head
so you have to be very emotionally
attached in kind of professions like
that I mean I think it was the writer
George Orwell once wrote that good men
sleep soundly in their beds at night
because rough men stand ready to do
violence on their behalf and I think
this is this is exactly why we need
figures such as such as James Bond who
who you know with a bit of poetic
license do exist in real life and why we
need certain Special Forces troops as
well
you